Ben Roethlisberger Saturday or on
Wednesday night you watch fights no I
watch the fights I didn't watch Rothwell
fight when you don't watch fights yeah I
did Wednesday night I didn't see the
fights on Wednesday I didn't watch the
Saturday I watched nope
fights run once they do a lot of fights
yep who else fought OSP Ross Rothwell
fought osp's ass a hot so thick how do
you do
he just he just looked like he was like
I'm gonna have you in that train has he
been injured her out for a while what
happened you just wanted to get a
heavyweight um hey brothel end up
winning a split decision nobody really
won it was a decent fight he lost so you
didn't see anything Smith Glover
Teixeira I did not oh my was that the
shoe thrown in the towel oh no nothing
Smith got [ __ ] by go over bad I would
never have called that bad no a-league
over was the underdog I know this is
great how about so clovers just beating
the piss on the fuse on top of him
Hinnom you seen him as you said he's a
very good wrestler you said Glover
Teixeira sand maybe Sea World Champion
yeah yeah I'm a phenomenal well you
think the jujitsu because he's presented
you don't think wrestling he's getting
everything yeah but he tough as nails so
he's literally beaten he's the nice guy
in the world yeah sure I've Anthony
Smith and he was I'm sorry this is
what's great about in the hammock rat
he's punching me goes I'm sorry it's
part of the job and as he's sitting in
Smith is out of it and he goes you think
they're about to stop and Smith goes
what and he goes I'm sorry it's part of
the job man I'm sorry
cuz he's such a nice guy and Anthony
Smith goes it is what it is man this is
you can hear it oh do I gotta see that
can't we yeah why not
I'm a junkie price shut it [ __ ] yeah
yeah Dean Smith goes it is what it is
man Anthony Smith's a bad mother and how
about how about how about end of the
fourth round did your high fight no well
that's their picture that where and end
of the foot just please don't you write
in fight but when Anthony Smith went to
his corner in the-- Smith is as tough as
they come
toughest guy in the world but still won
the John Jones fight off a DQ didn't
want to do it right I mean yeah killer
so he goes like this corn and goes my
teeth are falling out oh [ __ ] that was
ant I took that as Anthony Smith way
going hey dude we're not we're not spice
up the fight my teeth are falling out
corners like yeah cool store dude get
the [ __ ] back
my teeth are falling teeth are falling
out it's - I think he's such a great
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up you got to stop
the fight just fight another day I mean
also tell her I'm below the belt but you
see John's tweet Savage no because
you're not the Smith house they had a
robber and he beat the SH out of the
robbery
yes the burglar yeah John Jones tweeted
and deleted I bet you globe tech Sarah
wood I got that TV fine man oh [ __ ] it's
part of my embrace the villain here yo
sheriff saying he's giving up everybody
I want if I'm sorry it's part of the job
he's huh I'm sorry it's part of the
judges it is what it is he's getting the
globus on top just for four minutes
beatin his brains in can i he's at the
press conference that picture of him
does not look good man I'm Anthony hate
I hate when they take punishment
Orlovsky one again and do it for God
have forever
how long is Orlovsky bundu I'll tell ya
- humming it for real he'll do it just
20 years dude oh yeah I mean in the UFC
maybe for 15 no because you went he went
to world so yeah yeah but I mean while
Anthony just first fight in UFC was
probably 15 years ago yeah when him in
the tin silver fighting show they every
other week oh man I hate that his teeth
come on dude what they said it was his
veneers if that makes any difference at
all I don't know but if I'm born of my
my cousin's teeth are falling out
Messiah but I think this so big - man
he's such a good fighter
yeah yes Global tech chure quietly
Randolph for straight baby force age of
what he's 40 who did he beat the who's
the last guy he beat I think Smith
people over - no no a [ __ ] oh don't
bring it up I'll remember it he beat
Justin that's [ __ ] nuts no no he beat
Rashad oh god students beat Gustin
knocked out Glover Teixeira hold on
anthe Smith's last win was Vince no no I
know that I saw that fight I'm talking
about clover love it you said clovers
one for is one for straight yeah
well who else are Anthony Smith glad
cause I don't know all right cry loves a
monster he beat him split decision Wow
monster and this guy's the one that
played possum
remember yeah Jenny was knocked out yep
amazing dude decent night fights not as
good as Saturday - 49 this Saturday
doing fight companion what's how are we
doing that card starts that's it main
card search that's it all right decent
card it's free fight night I'm excited
excited
Mitch can't wait over in Walt Harris
your main event
cloudy good deja the dying piece oh boy
over him another one fighting since 1970
1817 doing the damn thing since 1917
yeah barbozza Danny whose hands were
he'll I'm seeing her she's on Rogen's
podcasting yeah she's great
this is a go fight there it's a great
song $1 ganders jock toes up ridiculous
light fun fights barbozza you got that
something's great fighters keep up with
yeah you should I keep up with a little
bit you try I watched every fighting
Saturday yeah there's a big paper yeah
this one is free on TV it's important no
one if it's old with knots that's me in
Florida yeah all the same place pro
sports going to Florida - I impressed
yeah pro sports you're gonna start open
up I'll tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]